guten morgen good morning everyone
the million that's Luxembourgish welcome
and hello good to see you
it's been hot Morgan Gama now I was very
pleased to come to Vienna this morning I
was
not concerned to actually get involved
in the ins and outs of the government
change but rather because I wanted to
come along and see what climbing machine
I was very pleased to actually see them
here today at this Parliament of the
workers also I was very happy to
actually find myself with similar minded
people in such a room is such a big room
so I'm very pleased that we are able to
to be that I'm able to be here with you
all today I'm also somewhat surprised
but no one has stuck to the rules that
Ruby set for us at the outset he asked
us to stick to the timing and I'm going
to try and be the first one to do it or
maybe I'll not we'll see how it goes
anyway I'm very pleased to be here with
you I'm very pleased because I have been
following the the et you see for decades
I've also been very active I was a trade
unionist before I joined any political
party and I can say to all of you dear
friends that I was also back in my day I
was also for the Labor Minister for
Luxembourg and I was very pleased to
have that job because I think that as a
Labour Minister you were working with
the daily ins-and-outs of the workers
you are far from all of the theories you
actually have your feet on the ground
when you are the Minister for labour and
I must say that really has been a useful
experience for me and I've actually
maintained my contacts with the trade
unionist even since becoming the
president of the European Commission
it's easier of course to be a dredging
Yunus when you're not president of the
Commission but when you are it's very
good for you to realize where you've
come from it's very good for to remember
that I've been following the ETU sea
since it started out as a pro-european
trade union Comfort Confederation which
we've seen this under Rudy we've also
seen it with Luca and I'm sure it's
going to continue with its low home and
it's going to oh it's always been our
tradition it's great for me to see all
of my good old friends here Emilia for
example and others respect my good and
old friend and I'm very happy to see
Bernadette here today different
languages but I will not express myself
in English everybody understands English
but nobody understands England so I will
Express
[Applause]
so you fit max which means I'm going to
switch to French I will start in German
so I'm very pleased to be here with you
and I must say Luca has already
presented a number of the issues that we
want to look at I must say that I'm very
pleased that I could actually agree
virtually word-for-word with what he
said and what I've seen also in the
manifest of the ETU C I'm very pleased
to be able to see that my ideas have
actually found form there in 2015 I was
also able to attend the ETU C Congress
in Paris and I knew that at some point I
was going to come along to attend the
14th Congress of the e2 you see and I
was hoping that I would and should have
become along but four years ago I didn't
think that I would be able to be in the
position that I'm in today talking to
you and that's why I wanted to look at
the priorities off the European
Commission which were decided on the
first November 2014 when I took up my
office more shows were growth investment
in innovation social justice
those were are the catch phrases back
then those those were the motto of the
Commission and they're not simply empty
words we have tried to actually prove
through our acts that we are convinced
but by our this argument that the social
Europe is something that we should take
serious and we should always do this we
must always keep our word if we promise
something to the people which is why
this Congress being held here in Vienna
is in precisely the right place and at
precisely the right time because it's by
working together that we can show that
we're prepared to fight for what is
worth maintaining and it's worth us
showing that for the next decade for
Europe it's important that trade unions
continue their work so that Social
Democrats Christian Democrats and others
are able to stand up and fight against
danger from the extreme right to the far
right that's what we all want to do we
want to stand up for our values our
sphere when on the first November 2014
when we first came to party into into
office Europe was in a tripled crisis an
employment crisis investment crisis and
a googol crisis of growth we tried back
then to bring that to bring some order
to the situation but when we started out
there are few jobs being created in
Europe under the last commission 600,000
jobs were created for the last four over
there for the five-year period under
this commission I'm very proud to say
under my commission thirteen point four
million jobs have been created when we
started unemployment reached a 10.5%
it's now at six point four percent it's
gone right down we're now at the lowest
level since official figures were
collected from 2000 and when the year
2000 and youth unemployment as well even
though it's still too high it's gone
down from 21 to 14 percent
if we had thirteen point four million if
we had thirteen point four million more
jobs or than thirteen point four million
unemployed if we were able to do that if
we're able to balance that out then we
would have work miracles
without these jobs that were created the
youth unemployment rate would have been
22 percent and that would have been no
doubt put at my door people have said
it's my fault but the fact that we have
now created these jobs is not something
I'm thanked for but look I did recognize
the fact with his fine Italian vision
he's very clever indeed to see that
their acts are not anonymous anonymous
that acts are always to can always be
traced back to an individual taking a
certain step so we now have only got 200
and we have brought down the
unemployment level in Europe from 22% to
14% we have actually increased
investment we've increased investment
across Europe investments are not done
simply for the benefit of investing
money but to actually produce jobs and
to help the workers of Europe in 2014
and 2012
they grow threat was not 0.4% there had
gone down four to naught point four
percent from 2012 2014 but now in this
following in the following quarter we're
going to see a growth rate of two
percent across the Union
and that is part of the Yunker plan as
they call it 400 billion euro additional
investment has been brought has been
generated for Europe through the Younger
plan so it has been a success now when
the fort was a successful I mean
everyone thought that we were going to
actually have to change the name and
make it we want to actually blame
someone else but it has been become a
success it's a European fund for
strategic investment the FC it's now a
successful planet is called the Younger
plan and I'm very proud of that and I'd
like to thank the ETU Sea for having
supported me from day one
onwards in developing this investment
plan for Europe I'd like to thank you
for helping me to get this up and
running and then of course we wanted to
stop this blind territorial approach to
things and then we've done this by
ensuring that the stability is pact the
growth and stability pact has become
much more flexible has become much more
reasonable has actually been focusing
more on developing economies I was very
concerned and before I was this I was
the chair of the Euro group and I was
very upset to see people behaving in
such a way as if the financial economic
crisis had actually arrived from nowhere
but that's not the fact these crises
come because the major forces of the
European banks or because of the
European powers were not actually
investing in the social market economy
but simply looking at profits and where
they can improve the profit margin it
was bound to fail and that's what we had
to actually bring back to onto the right
tracks I was very pleased that back then
in 2000 and 2014 I was able to actually
convince the Commission that we should
take a different direction
and I was not all Member States would
agree with me I remember the past with
Greece we had an awful lot of
difficulties trying to get some type of
respect from the
the workers in Greece because of course
I think that you had to they they were
not respected they had not been
respected in the past this was a
historical historical error of the past
being in Greece where the workers and
their rights and their living sons were
not being respected so we had to bring
about a certain degree of flexibility
and that was I think very helpful we
know that we have a brief of red
population a brave brave set of workers
also in Italy we were able to help Italy
as well with 13 billion euros which were
able to help the our European our
Italian friends they didn't have many
friends but we were able to actually add
to to help them over at the amount that
we would have been able to provide had
we stuck to the strict terms of the pact
of the but I think then we had European
growth will he not put 8% and the need
for investment was rather large 1.6
percent went worth today can be can be
traced right back to these actions by
the European Commission so no one can
say that the European Commission has not
actually been active for creating jobs
and developing the European economy
because if you want to invest in the
work the workers of Europe that is
precisely what Europe has been done and
we don't hear it often enough afterwards
what we did in November 2017 where we
adopted the European pillar of social
rights
now it's something that's been a dream
for quite some time we dreamed of
setting up this pillar of social rights
this minimal level of rights it says
that about 20 principles it's something
that it's not just something that we
talk about it's something we actually
implement the Commission presented 24
legal facts since the beginning of its
mandate and 15 of these pertain directly
to the pillar of social right Luke spoke
about a number of successes that we've
had we together suppose you and us have
worked together and we were able to
implement a number of these there was a
revision of the directive on fair
working conditions it's not small beans
no it's something that goes all the way
back to 1991 but what we've done is
we've boosted the text we've made the
text more secure from the point of view
of workers workers need security they
need security and certainly as much as
companies do the atypical work contract
and that's something we've dealt with
now it's quite old I'm quite old as well
but back in my day we didn't really have
these contracts now back in the day you
had permanent cut working contracts
those were the were in the normal
contracts not these new type of
contracts my father was a worker in the
steel industry now if he was worried
every six months about losing his job I
would have actually it would have been
quite difficult but I think what we need
is we need security for these workers we
didn't even wait for the pillar of
social rights what we tried to do is we
tried to come up with directives on this
subject and there's the issue posted
workers as well now I wanted to say that
you need equal pay for equal work in the
same company so posted workers have
become modern slaves no what we need to
do is we need to protect their rights
and we've done that it's something we
wanted to do and we didn't listen to
those who tried to stop us to listen to
those who tried to stop us doing this
along the same lines we set up the
European labor Authority it was a big
debate around that most member states
didn't want to follow us on this path
back then however I said we have a
banking authority why don't we have a
laborer Authority we have it now thanks
to you and thanks to my new job Rodrigo
who co inspired shall we say the pillar
of social rights this person was with me
as Minister of Labour back in the day
and this allowed us to push forward a
social Europe but what we need is we
need to have a minimum European wage all
workers in Europe should have a minimum
wage will allow them to live to live
decently without having four or five
jobs and worried about losing their jobs
we need a minimum wage in Europe now
[Music]
there are some things we need to stop as
well I don't like this idea that's going
around this idea whereby we should index
family allocations and social locations
no I think that any worker who works in
a country this worker has the right to
the same allocations as the worker who
lives in the country even if their
children live abroad so it doesn't
matter a worker is a worker a child is a
child they should have the same rights
all of them should have the same rights
that's why I'm going to keep fighting
for better coordination of social
security regimes the commissioners
proposed such a system the council
hasn't been able to adopt it but I do
hope that the next commission will keep
pressing this in order to ensure that
the guiding principles that we have
proposed be maintained and then there's
tax policy I believe I'm fully convinced
in fact that these big Internet giant's
need to pay their taxes they need to pay
their taxes to national Treasuries it is
not acceptable that small companies
mechanic a butcher if they have to pay
the maximum amount of taxes where is
these big gigantic multinationals
getting around their tax obligations so
we've proposed a directive to ensure
that these taxes be imposed and I do
hope to the next Parliament and the next
Commission keep on the pressure when it
comes to implementing this directive a
directive that is based on good sense
and wisdom has been done or has to be
done what is one issue more which is as
important as those I mentioned and which
to some extent is more important we have
to fight for the rule of law that's the
duty of trade unions to is not a trade
unions the one who is not doing
everything to fight in favour of the
rule of law because the rule of law is
protecting the weakest part of our
society so we have so many things to do
in the next coming years to leave the
Commission but I'm actually quite
relieved as well I'm quite relieved that
I can retire but one thing that I'll
miss is this meeting the ETU see I'll
miss you
I couldn't imagine living without being
annoyed by you every single day on the
phone Luka Rudy I have to cross over the
street whenever I see them in Brussels
but for me this was a great pleasure and
I learned a lot long live trade unions
[Applause]